foreign
Texas show what's up Erica hi Dr John
how are you I'm good what are you doing
yeah I stepped outside of my office for
a bit to take this call so very cool so
what's up
all right so there is
a man I know through church we do not go
to the same congregation but we're in
the same denomination we live about an
hour apart from each other okay and I
have through knowing him through church
functions and just knowing them about a
year and a half have developed feelings
for this person oh
is he handsome
I think so babe
says people like oh is he good looking
she's like
I think so good job Erica good job all
right so you've developed feelings for
him okay so what do you like are you in
or what
I told him about two weeks ago how I
actually feel yes way to go
seemed very shocked he seemed to have no
idea okay and he's like what do you mean
I'm weird I'm strange I'm not feeling
worthy what are you talking about and I
just lay it all out there I'm honest
with him I had I told him I had to be
honest with you
you know even if it's one-sided I felt
that you deserved to know that this is
the dynamic that I'm coming at this from
and I have not heard from him in two
weeks
it is normal for me not to hear from him
for a couple weeks at a time because of
his work and other Church commitments he
has
so it's not the not hearing from him
that is worrying me I'm just wondering
where is the balance between
I need my answers on how you feel so I
need to either connect or move on versus
your boundaries your schedule your roles
as a man in your church Community like
where is that line in that boundary of
both of us getting what we need out of
this well unless he's put that that
unless he's put that boundary out there
it doesn't exist you're imagining that
boundary and it provides you some amount
of safety because you laid it all out
there and dude I'm proud of you how old
are you
30. dude I'm so proud of you how old is
this dude
uh what
um yeah like has he ever been married uh
no he has never been married he's the
one that was like if I can tell within a
few dates that it's not going to be
marriage potential I'm not going to
waste my time what a knucklehead
you know who says that 53 year old
single idiots good grief
um listen
I anyway I had that same idea and if I'd
kept to it I still would be single
because I can find something anyway so
here's the deal I'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt okay I never met
him I don't know him but I am feeling
optimistic today okay
I think
with all of my heart this is a skills
issue
and if he was my friend
I would be razzing him like crazy you're
telling me a beautiful 30 year old woman
just walked up to you and said I've got
feelings for you
um and you just
got back in your truck and drove off
like what's the matter with you know I
mean I would be giving him a hard time
but
I want to honor the fact that this
probably hasn't happened a lot in his
life is that fair
yeah that'd be fair to say and he
probably doesn't know what to do next
and he's probably terrified of these
scary little things inside of him called
feelings
right and that's why I wanted to
respected him to like give him the time
to process what I do no you laid a
grenade in his house and you're worried
about whether it went off yes it went
off
so
until he sets up a boundary
I would I would have already I mean if I
had the same conversation you did if I
found myself a nice 53 year old woman
and I that's just too weird I'm married
um I was trying to go with it but it
just sounded just was going to get off
the rails
um
it you laid it out there
it's very fair for you to call him back
and say hey we're getting coffee
and we're getting coffee on Friday or
Saturday and then you sit down with them
and say hey I told you I liked you and
you just say anything for two weeks
what's what's what are you thinking what
are you feeling
and if he says well okay I don't have I
I don't you don't you say no I am a
grown woman and I get to like who I like
and I like you
I would like you to ask me on a date
or because it's the 21st century you
could say I'm asking you on a date
and literally what you're doing is
you're walking up to his perceived
boundary and you are knocking on it and
you're saying can I come in
and if you knew this
he might say no because all relationship
is at risk
I think he would be making a terrible
choice but he might say no
what do you think if you did that what
do you think he would say
I mean I would love to Hope he'd say yes
but he's one of those that
yeah he's he's such a sweetheart that in
order to not upset somebody he might do
something that thought of his comfort
zone you
man
that's all I don't want him to do that I
don't I want him to be honest with you
I'd rather get an honest no than an I'm
too sweet to tell you no yes I know but
you hear what you're doing Erica well
this is a whole other phone call
you are already setting up the seeds for
where he can't be successful
because he's gonna say sure
and your first response is going to be
you don't have to
and then he's going to start doubting
himself
if you don't want to do this don't just
do it to make me happy and he's going to
be like uh I don't I thought you uh okay
see what I'm saying
yeah you are worth going all in
and if it doesn't work if he said looks
at you and says honey you're just too
young or I just don't have feelings for
you or I'm just an old man and I just
want to be single
it will hurt like bloody hell
but if he says I'm in
Erica it'll be awesome
I completely agree all of our friends
are already trying to sail the ship
gross gross gross gross but you see what
I'm saying
this only works if you walk over there
and you believe I am worth being in
relationship I'm freaking Erica
and
I like you and I get to like whoever I
want to like
and so I like you and I put it out there
and then you just did whatever you do I
don't know what he does for a living but
you just got in your car did your thing
and didn't call for two weeks by the way
never again can you do that if I put my
feelings on the table you get 48 hours
and then we're gonna talk about them and
he gets an opportunity to say hey that's
too quick for me
sometimes I need a week and see what I'm
saying now y'all are starting to say
your needs out loud and you're starting
to be honest with with each other and
you're practicing it and he's going to
need a lot of practice because this is
new for him fair
and so part of you knowing that I'm
going after a single 53 year old guy
who's never been married never been a
long-term relationship is
he's going to do things a little
unorthodox or he's going to have some
skills to learn or he's going to have to
learn the new protocols right of how
people you grew up in a world where
there was text messages he grew up in a
world where there were carrier pigeons
right very different planets
I mean I and I'm completely willing to
work on that I've got whatever learning
curve I've got the learning curve myself
of the only relationships I've ever been
in or bad ones you know we we each have
our own learning curves yes I expect if
I expect him to work on mine
yes all day all of us have learning
curves when we get into new
relationships whether we're going to
work at a new at a new job whether we
have a new kid whether we are
married and we have are the dynamic of
our relationship has changed after three
years or five years or seven years or 20
years
we all have to quote unquote work on
ourselves and work on our relationship
all the time that's the beauty of it
it's when you start trying to plant
seeds
to feed yourself in an apocalyptic
winter it could go wrong or he might
just be saying yes because don't do that
if you find out six months from now he
just said yes because he was too
insecure to say no and he never liked
you
never wanted to kiss you never wanted to
hold your hand in the movie or whatever
he just did it to go along with it
because he was too nervous to say no
that would be devastating and
heartbreaking
and it will still be better
than if you go into this relationship
you put yourself out there you follow
back up and say hey dingbat I haven't
heard from you in two weeks I put my
heart on the line what are you doing
and he says I'm all in
still worth it
is that fair yeah he is no no no you
you're worth it I don't care about him
he didn't even call you back
okay you're worth it
even if he even if he tells you no
you were honest with you you were brave
for you you were vulnerable on behalf of
you
that's the good stuff in life even when
it doesn't work out
cool
cool here's your homework assignment
call him today and say we're meeting in
person don't let him off the hook with a
phone call
set up a time to meet in person in the
next 24-48 hours
and then you
don't go there with your head down say I
told you I liked you two weeks ago I
haven't heard anything from you
you're gonna have to talk about your
feelings like that don't sing to him he
might think that's weird
cool I mean I was that theater kid I
could think
I know you could yeah that hey that
uh I would probably be freaked out a
little bit by that but hey you know what
Erica you do you you like go for it he
needs to know what he's getting into so
if you can burst into song at any moment
who knows but sit down and be honest
with him sit down and say hey
where are you
where are we
and by the way if you're married been
married a long time my wife and I we 20
years of summer we just had this
conversation where are you where are you
and one of the greatest Summers ever and
then we're in the halfway through the
fall and it's already getting hard
how do we get back on track how do we
control delete and start again
and yes it's exhausting and yes it's
frustrating and yes it is reality
so let's get back on the way I can start
again
let's go again Erica have a conversation
and you gotta report back you gotta let
me know what he says
I can't wait to hear